hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday
October 17th
2022 what's going on how are you
yeah I was a guy that [ __ ] lights
burnt up I gotta fix that
you know I'll tell you your day just
never seems to end does it people and
people who don't have children just
can't understand
um
how much is that like a [ __ ]
like
thing that human beings do
like they're always pointing like well
unless you do what I do you don't
understand
you know
whatever the emotion you're feeling you
don't know what laughter is until you've
done X Y and Z you don't know what
crying is
until you're getting your vag waxed and
the power goes out you know whatever the
[ __ ] is it true
whatever the [ __ ] they're doing it's
like no everybody knows it everybody
just knows different degrees different
degrees is different different degrees
of it
if you knew the podcast this is the
level of intellect on this thing
different degrees of it
like I remember one time uh
I was [ __ ]
I was I don't know what the [ __ ] I was
doing I was doing some I did up like my
millionth School
in the state of Kansas
and I was trying to explain it to this
guy
the guy I forget what the [ __ ] I was but
the guy was like Bill nah nah don't tell
me about Kansas
and I was like all right and I found out
he spent a weekend up there with an
ex-girlfriend and then all of a sudden
he just [ __ ] knew everything and I
had to shut the [ __ ] up and meanwhile I
had probably stood in about 40 different
cafeterias
in front of these college kids in the
late 90s and 2000s who had no idea that
there was going to be a show eating my
balls and then driving
you know I don't know how many what the
[ __ ] did I know this guy spent now bam
don't don't tell me about cancer now
don't even try to tell me about that
state I was there for three days that's
all I need
you know
I got a bunch of East Coast friends that
came out here for a weekend and told me
Hollywood is so phony and plastic it's
like oh wow you really got around yeah
you know how many people did you even
[ __ ] talk to what happened you came
out here and they didn't have they
didn't have a D'Angelo's and you freaked
out and saw some chick with big tits
walking down the street and you're like
it's just what I thought it was just
like how I already had my mind made up
that it was gonna be
um those are fun people to walk to uh to
be around you know foreign
first it bothers you by at first I mean
for two decades it bothered me and then
then I suddenly realized like well
what's great about that is that person
is not going to live out here so
it's kind of good you disagree with them
like oh yeah yeah this place sucks
that's that's why I live here yeah
everybody's fake everybody lies to you
yep not like where you're from everybody
just tells the truth don't they you know
when they give you an estimate for how
much it's going to cost you to redo that
bathroom I mean it is right down to the
[ __ ] nickel it's exactly what they
said it was going to be
you know all these Hollywood phony
people if only Hollywood people could be
as honest as somebody uh who redoes
houses
whatever the [ __ ] you call them
if only the the people in Show Business
could have the [ __ ] integrity
of the people on Wall Street of car
salesmen
of uh every other [ __ ] you know
that that's why I like meeting like an
honest truly honest I'm not saying
that's not like you know lying
[ __ ] in this business I mean
yeah obviously every business there is
that
um that's why it's so nice to actually
meet somebody that's like yeah this is
what's going to be and I don't
overcharge it and it's going to be done
on time and you're like are you [ __ ]
real Am I Dreaming this right now
um
I don't know maybe that's why people
steal after a while because when they're
actually being nice people people just
keep going like I can't believe you're
not [ __ ] me even harder and then they
start thinking oh should I have been and
then they start doing it right maybe
that's what happens I don't know I don't
know what happens
um uh I can tell you this I've had a few
good things happen this week I've had a
couple of [ __ ] annoying things happen
this week but I've remained even killed
you know we had some friends of mine
over and uh they brought their kids
something we've been trying to do since
before covid and they came over and
right before they came over
um
you know they were picking up coffee so
I said get me a Triple Espresso I know I
know this is my new Boost now I'm
[ __ ] into this [ __ ] so now I gotta
take a week off from coffee because it
has a little bit of a hold on me
okay but when I quit it I don't get the
headache so I'm not totally [ __ ] up
but like
I don't know that whole thing like I was
tired and now I'm not tired and now
there's all of these studies
that shows that it doesn't wake you up
it actually just blocks
the signal that you're tired I mean do
they really need to do a study on that I
don't know how something makes you
untired if you're [ __ ] tired you're
tired that's like being becoming Undead
the only thing that makes you untired is
sleep
but the problem is
is there's two groups of people that
don't give a [ __ ]
about your level of sleep your boss and
your kids that's it they just keep
driving the [ __ ]
slave driving you down the street and um
that's why I want somebody from Mexico
right now to chime in and I want to know
if the urban myth of the siesta
every day or whatever if if is that true
do you guys actually take naps in the
afternoon or some other country like
Spain you always say like those those uh
those little towns along the
Mediterranean and in the summertime you
know they just they everything just
closes around noon and doesn't open back
up again until like three in the
afternoon and everybody goes home and
just takes a [ __ ] nap
I don't know if it was Mexico I don't
know if it's Spain I don't know if it
was Albuquerque I don't know where the
[ __ ] I heard I heard it it sounded weird
to me when I was younger but now that
I'm old I'm like that sounds [ __ ]
amazing
imagine getting to work at like 8 30.
and just knowing you got a nap coming at
noon like a three hour [ __ ] nap
just as a country wouldn't you be
willing to drop in the rankings like the
Alabama Crimson Tide
that's such a douche
um to just drop in the rankings
why do we need to keep saying that we're
the number one country we know we're not
you know
I'm not saying you don't love the place
I'm not saying it's not one of the most
beautiful countries out there it
absolutely is to look at it
but we don't make anything here anymore
we keep printing all this [ __ ] money
inflation's going through the roof and
we blame ties he's got a blue tie and so
he has a red tie those people are evil
[ __ ] morons
um
you know we make here we make weed
and a lot of noise no what else do we
mean we got to make something else
um I know we make weed
and uh we make uh Shinola
I bought a watch from them
they make everything from bicycles to uh
watches I don't know they have a hotel
in Detroit right would it be great if
they actually [ __ ] made cars here
again
wouldn't it be great if somehow unions
and the people that run corporations
could actually actually stop being
selfish [ __ ] and find a [ __ ] middle
ground and bring some jobs back here and
just make a [ __ ] American car here
wouldn't that be fantastic
and what if the union guy took all his
[ __ ] benefits and then didn't lean on
a shovel and what if what if the
corporate guy didn't try to [ __ ] the
union guy so he'd go to Epstein Island
you know everybody's got their little
things that they're doing wrong wouldn't
that be fantastic
you know
she's going back to the times with
everybody in town you didn't have to
finish High School
all you had to do is just walk out of
your high school if you could go to some
place and buy a lunch box you had a
[ __ ] job
right little hard hat you put your local
[ __ ] football team's logo on it or
whatever
you go to work you laugh you have a
great time you drink Boilermakers you
will you ignore your family
you know you drop off a heart attack in
your 50s like what was wrong with that
America
now look at us we don't make anything
here and all we do is go on social media
and [ __ ] Photoshop our lives right I
don't know I'll do it but a lot of
people do it
you know
not me man because I'm so [ __ ] real
no I uh
I don't Photoshop my life there's
nothing to photoshop you know if I was
going to photoshop my life I would have
first got hair plugs
um you don't post enough on social media
oh yes I do
yes that the world does not want to look
at a bald Ginger every day and what his
life is like okay you know what it's
like I'm constantly going to CVS trying
to find a higher sunblock
as we slip into whatever the [ __ ] this
next thing is with nature is
um I'll tell you what I did do is I
cleaned out my [ __ ] closet like I had
uh I had so much goddamn [ __ ] and I'm
doing this tour and people are giving me
a lot of gifts and stuff like that so
I'm just it's which is amazing but it's
[ __ ] funny man making
insane money I don't you know they still
because it just I don't know what it is
so um I was like all right something's
got to give here and I looked at my
closet I was like I don't wear 90 of
this [ __ ] and I just [ __ ] broke it
down to what I wear and what I don't
wear
and all of a sudden it was it was nice
so uh but I'm not throwing it out it's
not going to the ocean and I'm not
taking it down to that half of Face
Place whatever the [ __ ] it's called down
there looks like the letter G and it's
smiling at you
Goodwill bam G Goodwill got it you know
they dump half this [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
warehouse and eventually it ends up at
Sea World and that's why those those
goddamn killer whales are constantly
[ __ ] attacking their trainers
you know what I mean they're swimming
around with like OSH Bosh all that
Oshkosh [ __ ]
what do you call those what are those
nice galoshes
LL Bean ruined the galash you know by
making those Duck Boots like fashionable
um I don't know what I'm talking about
um anyway so I'm getting rid of a bunch
of that [ __ ]
and uh
you know all of these [ __ ] stupid ass
suits that I bought and all of this [ __ ]
that I've just had for years
and like suits are so [ __ ] dumb
if you buy it like a crazy patterned
suit it looks great for like about a
year and then it just goes out of style
whatever [ __ ] Anchorman [ __ ] that
people retro thing they were trying to
do it just [ __ ] goes out of style
so
I think I'm gonna go to indochino and
I'm gonna buy like [ __ ] four suits
I'm not gonna tell my wife I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna go to indochino this is
not an ad
this is just the truth because I went to
a [ __ ] wedding
and I blew all this money in the suit
and this guy had the best suit there I
go what'd you get this scene he goes if
it goes this suit was 175 bucks I think
he went to indochino but had a really
cool pattern and then he had a nice
shirt with some shoes on cufflinks and
stuff and like nobody [ __ ] knows
nobody gives a [ __ ] and then if you
spend 175 bucks in the goddamn thing you
don't give a [ __ ]
you don't give a [ __ ]
if you get a little [ __ ] uh a little
salsa on it later on that night
so uh I think I'm just I'm just gonna
clear the [ __ ] table
and um
you know everybody talks about how
[ __ ] Einstein
you know figured out how to make a bomb
that could wipe out all those people you
know and he equals m c squared and all
that you know and they but the big thing
that stands out for me because I don't
understand how any of that [ __ ] works
I mean don't get me wrong I was always
trying to buy illegal fireworks but you
know but as far as it went
um
I like that
that he had he wore the exact same [ __ ]
every day
I'm sure his wife didn't like it you
know
dude that guy was so smart he didn't
even brush his hair
like that's how much he was thinking
you ever noticed that like people who
were like super smart always have like
sleep in their eye and stuff it's like
like when
they're like looking in the bathroom
mirror like they don't even see
themselves I just figured I just you
know those movies when somebody's really
smart they just they superimpose over
their face like all these fractions and
numbers and squiggly lines with letters
floating by
what's funny is nobody in the writer's
room knows what any of that [ __ ] means
and they're just like you know math [ __ ]
floats across the face of the main
character
um
yeah like I feel like when they brush
their teeth like that's what they see
you know
I don't know if they do that I just
watched too many movies about smart
people you know then all of a sudden
they just have like an idea and they
grab their wife's lipstick and they
write it on a [ __ ] mirror
and they storm out of the house and then
like the wife comes home later and she's
just like Albert
bought you a sandwich
he senses something's wrong and she's
just like Albert
and then she rushes upstairs you know
and the wind's blowing through the open
window and she just looks in the mirror
and it says E equals m c Square
and she gasps for breath then she sticks
her head out the window and then we have
a long shot of the house and she's just
like
Alberts
um
that was Egghead Sleepless in Seattle
like what if Tom Hank's character was a
scientist right and Meg Ryan's character
was still whatever she was I never
really I started to watch that movie and
um
I just didn't give a [ __ ] about either
one of them
you know it was just something about
them talking on the [ __ ] phone
and uh
I didn't know what they were talking
about but it was like [ __ ] annoying
like at no point did Tom Hanks ever be
like hey you know uh
so what do you look like what are you
wearing come on it's late
gives a [ __ ]
you know you got your titties out
rated R Sleepless in Seattle
um I'm driving over there now
um
anyway
I had another great day with technology
I went to go uh
had a flight lesson today just to kind
of
you know blow the rust off whatever the
[ __ ] expression is
and uh I wanted to do a couple
approaches you know remember the
instrument rating that I was going to
get before my life got so busy
so we went to go do an approach and I
and I charged up
my my uh my tablet whatever the [ __ ]
iPad
I charged it up I was all happy I was
all excited that I actually thought
about that instead of 20 minutes before
I left and then I go up there with like
30 juice at a hundred percent and then I
get up there and I click on foreflight
and it's just like yeah your fourth
flight expired two weeks ago
but for some reason it was working on my
phone
and my instructor's like well that's
weird it usually lets you use it on
three different devices
and I'm I'm only using it on two
so that was like a what the [ __ ]
then I get home I have to listen to
music that they're composing for the
movie
um I can't figure out the password I
don't have it written down on my phone
to get into the the [ __ ] thing where
I can listen to it I'm like oh I know I
have it on my laptop and my laptop is
plugged in I'm like yes 100 juice and I
go and I [ __ ] click on it and
whatever reason like
the the
prongs coming out of the plug like one
of them wasn't quite in because they're
like collapsible like the travel one so
it didn't charge at all
and then in my podcast Studio the
[ __ ]
whatever the [ __ ] garage band doesn't
recognize something so now I'm doing
this on my phone and I was really just
thinking that I was thinking like
as far as technology making your life
easy versus the quality of life you have
constantly having to troubleshoot what's
wrong with the new Miracle device that
you bought
that you spent all this [ __ ] money on
that with within three years is not
going to be worth a [ __ ]
you know what I mean
that's the thing about that's the deal
about technology there's not going to be
like Mecum Auctions in the future coming
up next we got some Microsoft you know
power we got a 2002 home computer nobody
gives a [ __ ]
it's just over you buy cars you buy toys
you buy baseball cards all of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] video games old video games
everything appreciates in value
I guess video game stuff does but like
these [ __ ] laptops and the phones and
all of that [ __ ] I don't know
it's like fashion
you know your wife has to have something
right she's got to have this thing and
she puts it on and she [ __ ] looks
great and within two years if she wears
it again she looks [ __ ] ridiculous
right but if she just bought some
[ __ ] at the Gap she could wear it
for like five years
but you know the deal women can't show
up wearing [ __ ] from The Gap then the
other women they start judging them and
being [ __ ] mean
like so many of women's issues is the
[ __ ] that they do to each other
you know and I was trying to buy into
that feminist thing where they were like
well because that's the position men put
them in second society and it's like no
you guys are like [ __ ]
and there's no reason for it like you
[ __ ] Petty the level of pettiness I
I've maintained and I did the spit my
ACT I oh I really think
it's because they don't solve generally
speaking they do not solve
their problems with violence
and I think guys are just as big a [ __ ]
as women are but we always have it in
the back of our head if I go too far
this guy can beat the [ __ ] out of me so
there's like a governor on our cuntiness
where you guys it's just like wide open
um unless you run into the one
is that what they say or you're not are
you one to the one who isn't the one
right is that what it is
I love all of that [ __ ]
all that tough person talk becomes like
mainstream
you know
it starts off with some black chick
you're looking at like she looks like
she could you know you watch her fight
on YouTube you know I'm not the one
[ __ ] she kicks the [ __ ] out of
like some
other chick right and then like within a
month of that video
there's like some [ __ ] skinny white
chick douche and a yoga class going like
because you know because I'm like not
the one [ __ ]
foreign
but it's not all bad because then
there's other [ __ ]
where
like with instruments this this is this
is
a family of musicians there's these kids
man this is
brother and sister they can play every
instrument
as far as my ears can tell at the level
of like chick Korea they like closing
their eyes making faces just going up
and down the keyboard up and down the
fretboard up and down the [ __ ] stairs
playing these things and I'm looking at
like like their [ __ ] connection with
these instruments is they're more
connected with these instruments than I
am with the [ __ ] language that I'm
speaking
they're incredible now I'm not saying
that there weren't prodigies
you know back in the day but I just feel
like
but I think they would be amazing in any
era but just the fact that they're out
there and they're doing it
and the fact that like
mortals can watch it just kind of makes
everything move
to like a new level
which by the way I'm I'm really
embarrassed to say this as a huge hockey
fan who just has no time to watch hockey
anymore although I did watch the Bruins
first period
we're 2-0 five and three I mean five to
three beat the capitals totally missed
that game so the first period against
the Phoenix
coyotes
I like the coyotes man that's a badass
team you know
they're like uh they like living a
country song like they lost their Arena
they're playing it like a [ __ ] call
you can go to an NHL game in front of
like 5 000 [ __ ] people in Arizona I
gotta go to one of those things before
they inevitably move somewhere else they
lost their [ __ ] lease at their Arena
and now they're in um
I don't know where they are they're
playing like Arizona State or something
whatever their hockey program is no
disrespect to Arizona State but I've
never seen them in the Frozen Four
um
so anyway
there's a defenseman
on Colorado that people are saying is
gonna is changing the game
the most any defenseman has since Bobby
Orrin I think even Wayne Gretzky said
that according to Joe bartnick and I
started watching highlights of the guy
and
um
like this kid's Gonna Save hockey as far
as like that like the four checking is
so [ __ ] amazing that the game you
know goes through periods of really
being
bored boring I mean and I was watching
him and the amount of times he was
skating towards his own net when he
collected the puck right and people are
kind of clearing the Zone because
you know they're expecting to go up ice
and he would skate towards his
goaltender and he would fake right and
then break left or vice versa and he
would lose that forward now that forward
would be behind the play and all of a
sudden they would have like a breakout
like back in the [ __ ] 80s when I
first started watching it where like
I mean I just remember Fred Cusick every
[ __ ] two minutes Bruins with the
three on two a two on one a breakaway
that was just constant
like
excite there was constant like
um odd rushes
and the geniuses
of the game eliminated them and in doing
so eliminating them eliminated so much
of the excitement and so much of the art
Artistry of the game and the Beautiful
goals and all of that you know Michelle
Goulet and all these guys that I grew up
all of those guys
um
the Stassney Brothers Gila floor all the
Adams division guys that I used you know
we used to play those guys all the time
um
I just you know obviously the new
Gretzky Mike bossy all of these guys
dude Rick Middleton I mean the [ __ ]
[ __ ] that that guy would do in a
breakaway because there wasn't some it
wasn't like you know the lock and all of
that crap I mean I know they played the
lock in the Trap they just they I don't
know what it was
something happened with the defense just
got too good and this kid is showing
Mortals
how to beat this new style like they're
going to have to come up what's gonna
suck
is that like they're gonna figure out a
way to [ __ ] slow him down I don't
know how you do it but uh I'm gonna
start watching some Avalanche games like
and they won it last year and I missed
the whole [ __ ] thing I mean for good
reason I've been working on this film
but like
um
I I did get to watch
some sports this weekend because I was
finally home I watched you know I was
going in out in a you know in and out
you know watching the Patriots beat the
Browns
uh with zappy
um
you know I don't know I'm you know we
won the last two we beat the Lions beat
the Browns you know what I mean but at
least we beat him beat him pretty
soundly too I think
um
a defense looked great I watched all of
Tennessee beating Alabama and I was I
would have tore out my hair if I had
anything on top of my head
I mean what the [ __ ] Tennessee was doing
going for it on fourth down when you had
your [ __ ] foot on their throat at the
end of the second quarter on your own on
their 45 [ __ ] yard line going for it
on like fourth and sixth or whatever and
then they did it again
in the beginning of the third quarter
they did it again on the 42. it's like
it's like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you doing
like I was so [ __ ] pissed at those
two goddamn moves that I was literally
like I don't give a [ __ ] if they [ __ ]
lose now I was so rooting for him and
watching that kid uh Hyatt
I mean I never heard of that guy even I
know that that guy's a top 10 [ __ ]
draft pick he was doing like that Randy
Moss [ __ ]
like three yards down the field not even
looking back at the quarterback putting
his hand up like I got this guy
um
and that was against Alabama who
everybody says you know they're always
saying oh they could be like a [ __ ]
pro team or whatever what an incredible
game
uh congratulations to the Tennessee
Volunteers
um
I love that kid Gibbs on Alabama too
uh and I watched Michigan versus uh Penn
State and there was uh some safety of
some Corner came up made this
unbelievable [ __ ] play in the
beginning of the game where a guard like
pulled or something like that or he had
like the edge
and this 300 pound guy is like pushing
him to the outside the running back cuts
to the inside
or something like that and he reached
back as like a 200 pound safety and just
took the kid down with one arm and as he
did it I was like who the [ __ ] is that
guy
uh they immediately go one of the best
[ __ ] quarterbacks or safeties in the
nation so I guess the word word was
already out
um before a stand-up comedian scouted
him
[Laughter]
um
so I really enjoyed both those games I
will tell you as a sports fan I'm
getting tired of coaches
getting off the hook making stupid
decisions and they get to use the excuse
Analytics
like you sit there and go why the [ __ ]
would you do that well the analytics
said so I think half the time they're
making the decision it doesn't work and
they just go yeah the analytics said so
and they just saying it to a bunch of
sports writers who kidding who's kidding
no they're a bunch of donut eaters who
did okay in gym class I mean they're not
athletes by any shape of the me shape or
form shape of the means
what am I trying to say by any any shape
or form by any means
or shape of the means
Jesus Christ I'm inventing like new
sayings that really you know what I'm
doing I'm like a [ __ ] uh I'm like a
producer of music now you know I'm
sampling
I'm sampling uh hit sayings and just
tying them together oh [ __ ] he took this
from this and that from they took two
things that already existed and put them
together
um all right with that let's do a little
bit of the uh let's do some reads here
for the evening oh by the way I've been
going back to the gym that feels good
that feels good I ballooned up to a buck
90. I'm down now to like 183 and I just
gotta drop these last 10 pounds and I'll
be [ __ ] in shape again but I actually
have the time off like this last weekend
is the first weekend I've had off since
like [ __ ] July
and um
I got uh this upcoming weekend and the
weekend after and I'm getting along
great
of getting along so great
with my wife right now because because I
went to
buddy of mine's funeral
a few weeks ago and I just you know guy
was like my age and I just I just
started put everything into perspective
and I'm just like what the [ __ ] why am I
dying on every Hill I don't give a [ __ ]
all right I just want to get along with
my wife
that's what I want to do and someday one
of us isn't going to be here and then I
don't want to be thinking like going you
know I could have held her hand that day
and instead I argued about [ __ ]
taking out the trash it's stupid it's
stupid
um all enlightened Billy red face here
all right Roman everybody
you know 42 percent almost half
almost half in what world
you know
if I owed you 50 bucks wait if I owed
you 100 bucks and I said I'm gonna give
you almost half
and I gave you 42 bucks you'd
immediately think you're ripping me off
I feel like I'm only going to get 87
back 42 is not almost half 48 is almost
half
42 percent lives between almost a third
over a third and almost a half and I
don't buy that at all all right Roman 42
percent of men experience moderate to
extensive hair loss in their lifetime
hey
I experienced 100 of that all right
there are there are options available to
help stop balding in its tracks yeah I
think more and more people are doing
that and I'm wondering if I live long
enough will I be the only bald person
walking down the street
um not by choice uh the sooner a person
starts treatment for hair loss the
easier it is to keep the hair they have
Roman offers clinically proven
medication to help treat the treat hair
loss all from the comfort and privacy of
your home Roman offers both prescription
medication what the [ __ ] I'm hiccuping
Roman offers both prescription
medication and over-the-counter
treatments Roman also offers specially
formulated shampoos and conditioners
with ingredients that fortify and
moisturize hair to look fuller research
shows that 80 percent of men who use
prescription hair loss treatment had no
further hair loss after two years
you stop at dead in its tracks research
has also shown that men who use hair
loss just [ __ ] cure it
Jesus [ __ ] Christ
we know what you're doing
anybody balding are all bald people say
we ain't eating one more you [ __ ]
pills until you [ __ ] come up
with a goddamn solution
then it would be just a standoff uh
they'd win we'd come crawling back
research has also shown that men who use
hair loss treatments feel better about
their overall overall appearance
uh getting started is simple complete a
free online visit then a U.S licensed
health care professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan
if medication is appropriate
oh it's getting late I'm yawning should
I drink some coffee and wake my body up
Roman ships it directly to you in
discrete packaging with free two-day
shipping the whole process is
straightforward and discrete treatments
start at twenty dollars per month on a
quarterly plan right now Roman has a
special offer for our listeners use this
link to get 20 off your first order just
go to get roman.com
that's get
roman.comrr for 20 off
all right nextly but not lastly but
leastly
um stamps.com everybody ah my old
friends at stamps.com you know if you're
a small business owner you know how
important it is to be ready for the
insane holiday season and if you haven't
started preparing for the chaos of
holiday mailing and shipping you're
already falling behind
yeah that's right
wow that that line right there just hit
me hard all right I gotta I already have
one gift for my wife and I got to get
stuff for my kids all right luckily
stamps.com has everything you need to
make your life a whole lot easier uh
it's the 24 7 post office that you can
access from anywhere no lines no traffic
no hassle you've heard me talk about
stamps.com they've been sponsoring the
show for over nine years now thank you
to them for that and if you haven't
tried it what are you waiting for
stamps.com is your One-Stop shop for all
your shipping and mailing needs a
stress-free solution for every small
business yeah you go to the store you
buy the damn thing you have it [ __ ]
wrapped you bring it home you [ __ ]
run it through the thing damply a bug a
couple more [ __ ] and it's out the door
a stress-free solution for every small
business use stamps.com to print postage
wherever you do business all you need is
a computer and a printer get ahead of
the holiday chaos this year get started
with stamps.com today sign up with promo
code bird for a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no low
long-term commitments or contracts all
right
with that we have the questions for the
week by the way if you want to write
into the podcast
the email is Monday Morning podcast
gmail.com Monday Morning podcast at
gmail.com all right I kind of scrolled
through some of these these seem a
little intense this week so let me get a
little sip of water here
um
oh that's delicious
that is delicious
um
oh by the way so I went to the J you
know I went with a personal trainer
and I had a great [ __ ] workout and
then the next day my shoulder was
bugging me I was like God damn it is
this ever gonna end and I just but I
rolled it out
and after two days it felt fine and
yesterday I said [ __ ] it I went to the
gym it was time to do upper body again I
did upper body again and it felt totally
fine and I think I finally
I'm finally going to push through I
finally have enough free time
and I also am finally not going to try
to increase the weight too fast
and I'm going to get over this thing and
uh
you know I'm back to doing lat pull
Downs with 50 pounds all I need to do is
just slowly work my way to about 100 and
110 pounds
three sets of 15 and I'll be able to do
a pull-up again and then I can not lose
my bet with Paul verzi that I'll be able
to do 10 pull-ups when I'm 70 years old
and I will be able to do that I'm not
going to cheat either
okay I'm going Aaron judge on this [ __ ]
going totally clean but I'm not doing 62
pull-ups I'm doing 10. all right
speaking of which let's take a look at
that [ __ ] the [ __ ] Cleveland Indians
and the San Diego Padres
um Sierra Madres let's see San Diego
Super Padres
scheduled they didn't close out the
Dodgers did they
schedule
um oh my God they beat the [ __ ]
Dodgers
what
you gotta be [ __ ] kid hey
congratulations
to the Sandy they got to be going
[ __ ] crazy down there
that is [ __ ] odd I like the Padres
all the way back to Gary Templeton
back to Ozzy Smith when he first played
with them right and he first played with
them made that incredible bare-handed
guy didn't know him when he played with
them but I remember Gary Templeton that
great [ __ ] afro
and uh and of course the unbelievable
Tony Gwen they have not been to the
[ __ ] World Series maybe they've been
once since Tony Gwynn in 84. I want to
say they went one other time
can't remember
um any holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta tell
you he's a Red Sox fan that scares me
because I feel like all these big dogs
keep getting knocked out and it's going
to help the Yankees but meanwhile the
Yankees I think are down two to one they
might be playing today against the
Guardians
Guardians
it's funny you look up Guardians and it
says of the Galaxy
all right
oh my God tomorrow says demo
I got the blue set so we say oh cutter
is set is that how you say 407 any
Frenchies out there oh here's some
French for you uh what I said to my wife
the other day uh uh I gotta remember how
to say it
um
uh asanka
form uh
javet LaSalle
du sport
there you go
what did all of that gibberish mean uh
my schedule is crazy busy today but
tomorrow it's not busy
at five o'clock
in order to stay in shape I'm going to
the gym
I'm gonna get this [ __ ] thing down
people and I'm gonna do a [ __ ] show
in French in in Paris
that's my goal just because I just think
it's so [ __ ] funny that a meathead
like me would know how to [ __ ] speak
that language and then I could finally
give them [ __ ] in French for how bad
their goddamn English is because you go
over there and they [ __ ] look at
these stare down the goddamn French nose
at you and then proceed to butcher the
English language
you know
what's your favorite movie Tootsie
[Laughter]
what
um all right art Vandals
that's a good name for a band art
vandals
um there's a band called the vandals
aren't vandals
um
dear Bill I'm a 27 year old lady 27 year
old girl my friends consider me Meek and
polite I always tell them on the inside
it's more like Bill Byrne here oh yeah
yeah you're gonna
in your 30s people are going to say what
happened to you if you're like me
um I don't have a lot of anger pent up
but certain things in life ignite the
flames in me notice how she didn't say
ignite the flame in me she said ignite
the flames
uh in me which means uh she got a little
temper there uh I never thought I'd
write into the podcast but my anger this
week
I love how you say you don't have a lot
of pent up anger and then you say ignite
the flames and now
uh you're talking about your anger all
right I I've been there I've been there
and you know what right around 27 it was
weird
up until 27 I was like hey you know
I have a great life I'm a happy guy and
I don't know what happened
um I never thought I'd write into the
podcast but my anger this week required
me to do so even for therapy regardless
of whether you read this I love art
history
um I love the stories behind the artists
and the art and the evolution of it all
that's a really cool thing to be into
like I don't even know anything about
that and if you started talking about
that that would be fascinating I think
always like [ __ ] cutting their ears
off and
you know
eating broth their whole life and then
they die and then their paintings for
some reason are worth a zillion dollars
because five people dictate that market
um this artist died next door let's all
buy it and say it's great
um we have the ability to move the
needle
anyway I've devoted my life to studying
and appreciating it uh when those
self-righteous fools through tomato soup
on the van Gogh
to protest oil
oh my God why would they do that what
does Van Gogh have to do with oil
I quote lost my [ __ ] as you would say
you absolutely should have
I truly despise the idea that
destruction of something is Justified
because of some greater cause it's also
an excuses how so many people
think they are good people but they are
not
well it's always like a a good cause
you know or or the result you want is
good but how you go about it
anyway ironically their hair was dyed
using oil-based chemicals
and their clothes required oil to make
they can't possibly believe that they'd
make a difference it's more just a way
for them to feel special [ __ ] them and
all the righteous Thanks for providing a
voice for my internal anger no problem I
wouldn't say [ __ ] all the righteous it's
it's it's
there's two things that are really
combination okay getting in a position
of power and handling it
in in a healthy way is really difficult
and then rebelling against somebody not
handling their power well and you doing
that in the correct way is really
difficult like you know I would say like
with that me too [ __ ] right which
obviously the goal of it
was righteous and was correct
but you saw how quickly
it just sort of kind of went off the
rails
in sort of these wild examples of people
that clearly were not what they were
going after
and I I just saw like a number he had a
couple of friends or something like they
were just like innocent and they had to
like get put on the bench for like two
years
because everyone was just afraid of like
this new [ __ ] movement rather than
being like no you're 100 right there
shouldn't be abusive power these people
shouldn't be doing this women shouldn't
be afraid all of a sudden yeah 100 agree
with that but that right there was not
an example of that people were too
afraid to do that so then innocent
people start going underneath the
[ __ ] blades
um but
I'm not singling out
uh me too because that seems to be
the way it always seems to go like
there's a problem people want to address
it and that when in in addressing it
that addressing gains momentum it gains
power and whenever there's power it
attracts a certain type of person and
then they abuse it and then people come
out the other side going like wait a
minute this wasn't what it was supposed
to be about what the [ __ ] are we doing
here that happens all the time
um so those people are so I wouldn't say
[ __ ] all the righteous I would say God
bless anybody who is righteous and can
keep your feet on the ground and you
don't get caught up in the money and
horse that comes with being successful
with something
[Laughter]
once again overly simplifying I can't
believe they did that van Gogh's one of
the few artists that I actually know
about and I actually can I appreciate
you know a lot of this my wife's really
into that type of stuff and
I started going to it more and the more
I went to it the more I started getting
like this appreciation of us like
it's really interesting and there's
interesting people that go to it and all
that type of stuff and like and he's
seen this you know some douches that are
just trying too hard to be interesting
but overall I I really liked it but I I
don't know what tomato soup Van Gogh to
protest oil
that sounds like rich kids
you know
like who the [ __ ] even knows who Van
Gogh is before you're like 40.
no I knew if you didn't cut us they
didn't cut his ear off right
um oh you know what it is like you heard
the name but you didn't it's like Mozart
Beethoven I've heard the names if you
played me that [ __ ] I don't know who's
who you know what I mean but you know
you play AC DC Metallica I'm like that's
[ __ ] that's AC DC it's Metallica
I don't every once in a while I just go
on a tangent and I'm just like wow I am
really dumb
um dear billion burning beard I like
that one
how are you I'm a 30 year old dude from
Toronto great City great coffee in that
City I had a good time when I went there
uh uh and this person said I've been
listening to the podcast now for about
three years now
uh last night me and a buddy drove to
Windsor to see you live we couldn't make
the Toronto shows we were not going to
miss this one please tell me this you
had a good time everything was going
great you were killing we were having a
great time and so happy to finally see
you perform great so you're doing your
thing up there and I noticed the woman
beside me who was clearly wasted wasn't
really feeling your brand of comedy and
she started making backhanded comments
after all your jokes
I think it's a backhanded compliment
it's not a backhanded comment yeah well
you know it's just what I I'm the Pied
Piper of [ __ ] people who can't say an
expression right
um anyway she was bugging everyone
around us to the point even the guys she
was with was telling her to shut up
repeatedly which itself was getting
super disrupted so finally I had enough
I've been waiting forever this for this
show I wasn't going to just sit there
and put up with it so I turned politely
I say could you please stop talking
she looks me in the eye and like a
four-year-old says no
so I just roll my eyes turn away and try
to focus on your show five seconds later
what is she you know what she does Bill
she dumps her entire [ __ ] beer in my
lap
oh my God and it's a woman so there's
like nothing you can do
I'm shocked and absolutely [ __ ] livid
I just tried to focus my rage on the
show because I didn't want to be
disrupted but then a few minutes later
she grabbed my arm and says I'm sorry
like a toddler who was forced to
apologize you know what that was
probably because you didn't engage
and then she probably you know maybe
came to her senses
anyway so I soaked in this broad's beer
and blah and
and blinded with rage looked her dead in
the eyes and said shut the [ __ ] up
she gets all pissy and gets up falling
down drunk call me a bunch of homophobic
[ __ ] screaming I said I was sorry to
which I say [ __ ] you I just asked you to
be quiet you dumped your drink on me you
dumb [ __ ]
uh she trades places with the guy she's
with who is repeatedly to telling her
stop stop you do this every time we go
out now what is this [ __ ] guy doing
if you're gonna stay with her keep her
home or put her on a leash
anyway guy says which is hilariously
ironic considering not 10 minutes before
that you did a bit about red flags oh
that's hilarious anyway they're both
arguing being insanely disruptive I tell
them both to shut up people are trying
to watch and then the [ __ ] guy starts
talking [ __ ] to me oh God you know
what's sad about all this they probably
have children uh it's getting ridiculous
so I just focus because I don't want to
cause an even bigger scene and really
[ __ ] up the show eventually
the woman gets up oh my God this story
is unbelievable and leaves and the guy
immediately turns to me and said I'm
sorry man she is a [ __ ]
and starts talking to me about her
as I as strongly as I could say dude
just let me watch the [ __ ] show
my God these people are fascinating how
stupid they are that was the end of it
but now I'm trying to enjoy the last
chunk of your show shivering covered in
beer trying to focus while the Rage of
this [ __ ] is just festering
oh and you got to drive all the way back
to Toronto now please tell me you got a
hotel room what calm me down was
thinking to myself well I'm going to
write him and Andrew a letter tomorrow
and maybe if he trashes her on the
podcast it will all have been worth it
oh buddy you kidding me I'm thinking of
sending you something
uh the lights came on after the show and
it took everything in my power not to
start talking [ __ ] to them but I didn't
feel like causing a big thing in a
casino she had painted on eyebrows and
looked like literal trash like a little
Trash clown from outer space so I had
some
shots in the chamber but what can you do
we just let them walk away with her
carrying his balls in her purse
anyway [ __ ] her and her child is
attitude dude I don't know how I could
trash her any better than you're doing
it anyway [ __ ] her and her childish
attitude at the end of the day I still
had an amazing time seeing you perform
dude you are a higher being man if you
went through all of that
and you're still feeling like you had an
amazing time
um he said in your story about the
mushroom trip brought my mood right back
to where it needed to be I sincerely
apologize for the disruption that you
showing to anyone listening now who may
have been there that said everyone we
talked to around us after seemed to all
be on our side why wouldn't they be
absolutely love your work Bud F is for
family is a work of art thank you for
all the laughter you brought me through
the pandemic it's truly kept me going
best wishes to you and the family and go
[ __ ] yourself
um
you know at my age 54 I kind of look at
those people now like
you know that's beyond getting drunk and
the fact that he said that she does it
all the time like she is probably an
alcoholic and those people literally are
like mentally ill
it's like you're living with a [ __ ]
crazy person when they're boozing
um
I don't know I mean do I really need to
trash her I mean you kind of [ __ ]
just just by describing her
and that how about the poor bastard
that's with her
you know what I mean
it doesn't have the the [ __ ] balls to
walk away from it
and then brings her out in public
knowing how the [ __ ] she is
um
I don't know dude I I would have done
most what you did like if a woman dumps
a beer in my life like what am I gonna
it's a woman there's just there's no win
in it and it gets back to what I was
saying earlier of why they're [ __ ]
because if a guy does that to another
guy I'm like immediately it's just like
all right well I'm getting into a fight
[Music]
and what's is there anything worse than
getting into a fist fight when you know
you're wrong I mean it just takes like
20 out of everything you're doing
you know
um
until you get hit a few times then you
lose your temper but you know you and by
then it's usually [ __ ] over
um anyway I'm gonna talk to Andrew I'm
trying to think well I don't have any
DVDs or anything anymore I got I gotta
figure I have to figure something out or
at least the next time I'm there
uh I I gotta do something and this I I
[ __ ] hate that [ __ ] like that can
happen at my show sometimes
um
all I can say dude you handled it like
the [ __ ] Champ
and uh you know you called her a [ __ ] I
mean that's like game set match I just
don't know how to
I was trying to picture her I just when
I just picture her she her hair is like
sort of like uh I don't know it needs
conditioner it's like a [ __ ] Hazard
you know those people was
is that is that certain age and algae
gets to where they just look exhausted
all the time
that's just kind of how I pictured this
person or she's on her way there and you
know it's bad enough to be an alcoholic
but to be in Windsor as a raging
alcoholic in that unforgivable [ __ ]
winter that you have to go and that Lake
Effect [ __ ] snow
I mean that's why those people in
Buffalo are jumping on tables it's not
because they're fancy I mean they're
really in a celebratory way are trying
to end their lives both as citizens of
Buffalo and fans of the Buffalo Bills
[Music]
um I didn't see any NFL today oh there
was a great [ __ ] game I didn't even
tape it all [ __ ] the bills played the
Chiefs and I missed it
I didn't miss it I was playing with my
kids what am I supposed to do here all
right roommate issues
lackluster Carrot Top
foreign
you know what what the [ __ ]
I gotta be honest with you if you guys
have never met Carrot Top that is one of
the nicest dudes you're ever gonna meet
in your life I [ __ ] love that guy
um and evidently I am the lackluster
version of him
um which I am fine with
um
because he's he's definitely a better
human being than I am just a [ __ ]
great guy in every comic I know loves
him anyway uh I hope this email finds
you well huge fan of the podcast I just
transferred to a new school
and I've been having issues with my new
roommate he's been blasting music on his
speakers however that's not the worst
part he plays the same song on repeat oh
boy
when I say repeat I mean 10 15 times in
a row
the other night I ran into him in the
kitchen and told him dude I don't mean
to be a dick but you got to stop playing
the same song on on repeat it makes me
it's making me crazy he said in a
mocking tone it's making you crazy
really I said buddy I can't tell you how
many times I've heard these songs in the
past week he said I've heard them more
than you and they're not making me crazy
uh this next line I'm quite proud of I
said
you're an only child aren't you
hey man I gotta tip my cap to the
listeners this week you guys are [ __ ]
killing it I don't know what the hell
you need to listen to this podcast for
other than to get your [ __ ] props
that's [ __ ] great uh this seemed to
really tick him off which led to his
stare down it's also ironic because I am
an only child I said you're not going to
be cool about this I said
you're really not going to be cool about
this and rather than responding he went
to his room and played one of the songs
even louder than before I wanted to grab
my baseball bat and go De Niro from
Untouchables on his ass and his speaker
my question is could I have handled this
situation more appropriately or is this
kid just a [ __ ] this kid is absolutely a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh maybe I could have said something on
the lines of
when you
comma I feel or when you do this I feel
oh so you have any tips on letting go of
anger and moving on yeah you gotta move
out
uh can't wait to see you next time
you're in Portland Oregon vato Fair
photo I mean go [ __ ] yourself I don't
know how to say the rest of it
um
all right
um
you don't want to get kicked out of
school
and what can you do here
there's got to be something that you can
do here
[Music]
um
I mean this is one you know when they
say violence is not the solution
uh that's because they don't read emails
like this because I'm trying to think of
a solution and every one of them is
violent like don't do this [ __ ] what I
thought of was you should have walked in
there with the bat and just smashed the
[ __ ] out of his speaker
and and the [ __ ] something else don't
hit his laptop because then it's gonna
cost you too much money
just smash the [ __ ] out of it and just
be like next time it's going to be a
[ __ ] hit okay in a movie that's what
you do you do that in real life you end
up in [ __ ] jail and kicked out of
school so
the world needs smart people this dude
is a mouth-breathing [ __ ] [ __ ]
so
um
there has to be a way
I would just I would just uh I would
just make fun of how stupid he is until
he throws the first punch and then
defend yourself that's what I would do
like when it comes to him hey dum dum's
here
my brain can only handle one song at a
time I would literally just do that
hey I bought you a record and just get
him like a kid's record
something I don't know what I would just
annoy the [ __ ] out if you really want to
beat the [ __ ] out of this kid what you
want to do is get him to throw the first
punch
yeah friends though this is my dumb
roommate he listens to the same song 15
times in a row that's how dummy is and
this is the best part it's not even a
good song
see that's just lame
that's just like I just think you know
the old [ __ ] days the old days the
old days before all this technology and
social media and all of that you could
just go in there and you could [ __ ] that
kid up and then that would be the end of
the [ __ ] problem but what ends up
happening is now the [ __ ] like
[ __ ] rule the world Charlie Murphy
[ __ ] Run the World Charlie Murphy he
said it it's the [ __ ] truth the law
is on their side rules the the [ __ ]
money the settlement everything is on
their [ __ ] side that [ __ ] stupid
[ __ ] at the show in Windsor the law is
on her side times two times [ __ ] two
because she's a woman it's just it just
is the way it is
and
you know what I think if you actually I
gave you bad advice if you actually come
with this guy
um
like that I just I don't know maybe
there's just a way to find humor in it
you know
but that that is like I I I would not
have been able to handle that at your
age
um
I will say though when you said you're
an only child aren't you when you got
the best of them that really seemed to
bother him
so I think he really is dumb
so maybe that's your maybe that is your
playing the same song 15 times in a row
is to be you know
going after his intellect oh you could
just [ __ ] deal with it and move out
and just know that somebody like you
know what's the sad thing about that
[ __ ] [ __ ] is he'll have at least
five kids
you know [ __ ] it feels good right that
those people have
all but you know smart people have like
two dumb people have five six generally
speaking I'm painting with a broad brush
here there all right good luck with that
that actually
your email actually upset me more than
the dumb [ __ ] at the Windsor show
because at least with that guy the
relationship is over
and he could get some satisfaction
looking at the poor bastard that keeps
going home with her you on the other
hand I mean you just gotta survive this
semester
um oh that's what you can do proactively
find a new place to live
all right rather than acting like this
person is an insurmountable
obstacle
um turn it into a positive
by getting some great place to [ __ ]
live
and at this point just not living with
this person could be [ __ ] great
um or
or is there like a spy shop you know
where you can get that thing that blocks
the signal on a phone
maybe you do that
and you know
I don't know maybe you can do that but I
the the best solution is to just [ __ ]
Let It Go
and
um
I don't and just find a new place to
[ __ ] live
and I I totally hear you on the baseball
bat thing but you can't do that that's
not the solution
it should be but it isn't all right
truck Tunes Bill my twin boys loved
watching truck Tunes too
oh I never saw that I didn't even see
the first one
when they're when they were four and
five years old the guy that made it is
pretty clever a little goofy but
creative they watched it over and over
again they could name all sorts of
trucks and still can my wife and I still
sing these songs sometimes a kid might
like it too are you [ __ ] kidding me
my son would love I gotta see this let
me see what this is truck Tunes here we
go little truck Tunes
just the sound of those air brakes would
make my son go nuts
all right
all right now it's like really cheesy
Graphics showing all these different
fire engines pickups
well I bet you can come on and try it
now dance and clap your hands
oh my God this will drive my wife nuts
but I think I'm gonna have to show this
to her
[Music]
oh this is gonna be number one with the
bullet in my son's life
[Music]
is this Huey Lewis
[Music]
all right I'm in I'm in because every
kid's show has music is annoying is that
and this is at least trucks
so I'll handle that thank you so much
for the heads up uh that'll that's
fantastic all right that's the podcast
um
sorry to the guy that went to the show
in Windsor and sorry to that dude that's
dealing with that [ __ ] person
and sorry to the woman that likes the
likes art like like all these people I
just want to go to Comedy Show I just
want to enjoy art I just want to have a
roommate doesn't play the same song 50
[ __ ] times in a row
you know
this really gets down to my my problem
with the higher power
okay and the lack of work that he puts
into most of his Creations after the
mountains the Seas and the prairies
of the golden prairies and [ __ ] like
that his work on human beings is
extremely shoddy and his analytics is to
blame the devil right rather than saying
nobody you just [ __ ] kind of slapped
this one together and now it's
somebody's roommate you know
so maybe all that praise every week on
Sunday is starting to go to your [ __ ]
head and maybe you ought to get down you
know get back to uh you know square one
and figure out why everybody worshiped
you in the first place all right take
that higher power oh jeez [ __ ] old
freckles with a hard take on the [ __ ]
Lord there all right go [ __ ] yourselves
so check in on you on Thursday